bonsoir nous sommes le 11 octobre
bienvenue sur téléphiles soixante dix
huit pour le 7 8 en direct entre 18 et
19 heures nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité locale à commencer par la
semaine de l'allaitement maternel
c'est un rendez vous mondial qui se
déroule dans 120 pays en france cela
débute lundi bonsoir à margaret dickason
clar vous êtes consultante en lactation
vous résidez à noisy-le-roi elle doit
servir à quoi
cette semaine de l'allaitement alors la
semaine mondiale de l'allaitement
maternel est là pour rappeler au grand
public ainsi qu'aux professionnels de
santé que l'allaitement maternel est le
mode d'alimentation infantile qui est
quand même la norme biologique alors
vous nous expliquer pourquoi cette
semaine est si importante et puis vous
allez nous dire aussi en quoi cela
consiste en ce rôle de consultante en
lactation ce sera dans un instant à la
chronique échos du jeudi ce sera dans
une demi heure avec alice gastines et il
sera question du handicap au travail
mais déjà le reste du sommaire de ce 11
octobre en images avec elle les salariés
et des seize sécurité à guyancourt
inquiet le dirigeant de l'entreprise a
claqué la porte il ya quatre mois depuis
ils ne perçoivent plus de salaire la
liquidation judiciaire vient d'être
prononcée il a 22 ans il est inhumain et
benjamins du pays à créer une petite
entreprise plutôt original un
distributeur de chewing gum qui ne
fonctionne qu'avec des pièces d'un 2 ou
5 centimes
autrement dit cela permet de se
débarrasser de ces fameuses pièces
rouges
si au lieu de rembourser les soins la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie les
prévenus
opération santé active est une
initiative départementale d'abord
déployé à poissy le dispositif va être
testée prochainement à saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis les bleus à l'entraînement à
clairefontaine avant leur match amical
contre le japon ce vendredi et surtout
avant la rencontre face à l'espagne
mardi prochain une équipe de france
marquée par l'empreinte du psg 5 joueurs
du club parisien à la composent sujet à
suivre ce soir
la phrase du jour est signée jean
françois copé en course pour la
présidence de l'ump le secrétaire
général du parti de l'opposition était
en meeting jeudi dans les yvelines à
mantes-la-jolie devant près de 600
personnes la déclarer comme je le fais
dans toutes les fédérations je vous
lance un appel à la résistance étaient
présents notamment jean-marie they are
député de la 9e circonscription jean
frédéric poisson est député de la 10e
circonscription des élus qui ont donc
choisi de ne pas se rallier à la
position des deux poids lourds du
département david douillet et valérie
pécresse
les anciens ministres qui se sont
engagés du côté de françois fillon à
l'élection pour la présidence de l'ump
aura lieu les 18 et 25 novembre pour
quelques deux cent soixante mille mille
temps en france dans un instant nous
parlons de la semaine de l'allaitement
maternel auparavant le point sur cette
situation des salariés des seize
sécurité à guyancourt
le dirigeant de l'entreprise je vous le
disais a claqué la porte il ya quatre
mois depuis ils ne perçoivent plus de
salaire la liquidation judiciaire a été
prononcée catherine mulato et anthony
rech au téléphone bas camara commente la
déception jusqu'à finale de commerce de
versailles
ce représentant du personnel de
l'entreprise à es16 sécurité implantée à
guyancourt vient d'apprendre la
liquidation judiciaire depuis quatre
mois date du départ du gérant de
l'entreprise pour le maroc
les 13 salariés ne perçoivent plus rien
tout le monde est actuellement sans
salaire sans travail jusqu'à la décision
finale d
qui sera donnée par le cabinet thompson
et le juge
la juge commissaire et
pour la reprise du personnel une
prochaine audience devrait avoir lieu le
18 octobre devant le juge commissaire
pour étudier les propositions de
plusieurs candidats repreneurs
un autre volet juridique est en cours
celui du 19 octobre les salariés
défendront cette fois leur dossier
devant le tribunal des prud'hommes
car autre complication dans le dossier
des salariés n'auraient pas été déclarés
ceux qui sont dans la légalité seront
bien garantie pour leurs arriérés de
salaire et leur solde de tout compte
assure de son côté le liquidateur
judiciaire
à plusieurs reprises nous avons tenté de
joindre la direction sans succès la
première invitée du 7-8 de ce 11 octobre
margaret dickason classe vous venez nous
parler aujourd'hui de la semaine de
l'allaitement maternel mais déjà c'est
quoi votre profession consultante en
lactation
oui ça signifie quoi oui alors
qu'ensuite en natation mon consiste en
accompagnement des mamans avec leur
projet d'allaitement que ça soit pour
quelques semaines quelques mois voire
quelques années une association vous
être regroupées au sein d'une
association
oui l'association française de
consultante en lactation et à peu près
500 80 consultants en lactation en
france actuellement
moi même je j'exerce en libéral donc je
me déplace je fais des visites à
domicile des mamans pour les aider pour
les accompagner pour les informer sur
l'allaitement pour les aider à résoudre
des problèmes 6,6 ya cent ans donc ça
s'adresse aux mères qui veulent des
renseignements ça s'adresse aux
professionnels aussi ça s'adresse aux
professeurs professionnels de santé
également je fais des formations sur
différentes sujets qui touchent la
lactation
mais le message c'est quoi c'est de
donner des conseils pratiques aux maires
qui le souhaitent ou en tout cas aux
professionnels aussi qui voudrait avoir
des informations pour les communiquer
ensuite au moment où le but c'est de
véritablement militer pour l'allaitement
maternel est de convaincre aussi les
maires qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas le
faire je dirais méritait peut-être pas
mais soutenir et accompagner ces
éléments que j'utiliserai pour pour
expliquer mon rôle
quand la mère a décidé d'allaiter ce
n'est pas toujours facile dans notre
société d'aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que on ne voit pas
beaucoup de modèles dans notre société
demeure qui allaitent
il y avait toute une génération de
mamans qui n'ont pas allaiter donc on a
perdu un peu le fil de l'allaitement de
ceux des savoirs les connaissances le
savoir faire et les mamans qui ne
souhaitent pas allaiter les mères qui ne
souhaite pas donner le sang vous en
pensez quoi
alors déjà je ne juge pas ces mamans là
ça c'est très important
seulement je me pose la question à
savoir est-ce qu'elles ont pris leur
décision en toute connaissance de cause
est ce que l étaient bien informés en
prénatal sur l'allaitement maternel et
je me pose cette question parce que je
sais que ce n'est pas toujours le cas
c'est pour ça que vous intervenez aussi
auprès des professionnels pour ensuite
se soit en tout cas les mamans et
l'ensemble des informations à leur
disposition la semaine de l'allaitement
maternel 1 débute le 15 octobre il y
aura des animations partout en france
dans les yvelines également on va
s'arrêter justement à versailles il ya
quelques jours il avait déjà une réunion
qui était organisé par ces consultante
en lactation reportage de valérie
auribeau et d'élodie moine un personnel
hospitalier déborder un congé maternité
cours et des femmes qui travaillent
autant de raisons qui freine la base au
sein des bambins et même si la france
reste à la traîne
certaines femmes vont jusqu'au bout de
leur désir d'alerter et assument leur
choix comme c'est maman rencontrée lors
d'une réunion à versailles c'était
familial à la base
dans toute ma famille à l'été et puis
après j'ai compris que c'était plus
simple pour le lobby est plus naturel ça
lui donnait tout et puis bon en tant que
jeune je pense qu'on est tous les trois
là on se connaît tous fatigués quand
même un aspect budget c'est bête mais ça
fait réfléchir
je me voyais pas faire autrement en fait
c'était
dans la continuité de la grossesse et
voilà pour créer du lien avec ma fille
pour je sais pas france était de ce
naturel naturel mais pas aussi simple
que ça les études démontrent que les
femmes qui font le choix de
l'allaitement ont pour la plupart c'est
des études supérieures et sont
indépendantes
difficile alors de concilier réussite
professionnelle et vie de famille
pourtant certaines y parviennent elles
seront capables de dire mais moi ça me
plaît et je veux le beurre et l'argent
du beurre c'est à dire je veux continuer
mon métier reprendre mon travail
continue à allaiter mon enfant et elle
ne se laisse pas abattre par exemple à
la reprise du travail afin d'être mieux
informer les futurs manon se tourner
vers des associations spécialisées ou
écouter échanges d'expériences les
rassure dans l'agglomération des
animations et des rencontres sont
proposées autour de ce thème du 15 au 21
octobre
il y aura des réunions d'information à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 15 au 19
octobre dans les différentes pmi
d'elancourt de trappes de montigny ou de
la verrière et puis aussi une rencontre
débat le 15 octobre à 9h au secteur
d'action sociale c'est à guyancourt
place du marché je me tourne à nouveau
vers vous vous nous l'avez dit vous
essayé de donner le maximum
d'informations à ces moments pour
qu'elles puissent faire leur choix en
toute connaissance de cause pour vous
actuellement c'est quoi qui justement
influence le plus c'est le poids de la
société par exemple moi je dirais que
c'est le preneur société quand on me
demande quand on me pose la question sur
quels sont les problèmes que rencontrent
les mamans qui allaitent
moi je dirais que le plus grand problème
c'est
un manque de soutien de son entourage
canton annette et donc on espérait
certains arguments aussi parfois pour le
fait pour expliquer le fait que les
mères nous ne souhaite pas donner le
sens et pour laisser la place au père
aussi parce que par exemple ça isole pas
le père c'était une très bonne question
je pense pas le père a tout son rôle à
jouer
souvent on dit que le père est l'acteur
de l'ombre sont qui l'allaitement
maternel ne fonctionnerait par les
études nous montrent que les mamans si
elle continue à allaiter c'est souvent
grâce au soutien de du papa tu vas voir
allaitement maternel sans pour autant
que cela met à l'écart le père c'est
exactement les mêmes a certainement quel
est le principal argument que vous
mettez en avant pour défendre justement
l'allaitement maternel
c'est l'argument biologique le fait que
ça donne aussi toutes les immunités
possible à l'enfant ce sont les uns cia
saint il ya plein d'arguments autour de
l'allaitement maternel et à
l'attachement aussi l'attachement du
bébé avec sa maman les études montrent
que l'attachement est un phénomène
primordial aussi important que l'acte de
se nourrir ou entendez tout à l'heure
dans le reportage la france est en
retard sur l'allaitement maternel
c'est bien ça la force cet inventaire la
france est en retard il ya moins
d'argent c'était avant ça je ne pense
pas pas plus que les autres pays
industrialisés est un des états unis
l'angleterre
globalement les pays industrialisés sont
en retard si on compare un petit peu les
chiffres avec si on compare avec les
pays en voie de développement
mais bon c'est le taux d'allaitement
l'initiation en france est en
augmentation constante
on est à plus de 70%
un taux de d'initiation en france juste
pour rebondir encore sur le reportage
dont on voit quelques images on a
entendu une des mamans nous expliquer
que c'était aussi pour le coup ça coûte
moins cher d'allaiter son enfant aussi
ça c'est l'argument qui finit de
convaincre alors justement les deux vous
pour ou contre l'allaitement maternel
êtes vous convaincu notamment par les
propos de notre invité voici un micro
trottoir et je trouve que c'est mieux
que c'est l'enfant qui donne ça la
tétine en ce moment plutôt que faire
parce qu'on sait parce qu'on a en fait
c'est tu les grands sociétés qui ont des
produits à vendre
on sait pas ce qu'il ya dedans le
naturel c'est mieux pour parce que c'est
quand même plus mieux pour l'enfant quoi
c'est plus ses meilleurs quand on peut
le faire c'est bien
a priori je serais pour est bon c'est
sûr que ça fait bien démarrer le bébé a
faim je pense en ce qui me concerne
j'aurais eu 3g zepa l'été mais bon pour
les autres mamans que je souhaite moi je
pense que ça peut être bien
je suis pour pour les pour les bébés
bien sûr c'est mieux je pense mais il
faut que la mer ne soient pas
culpabiliser ceux ne souhaitent pas
allaiter
je suis pour parce que moi j'ai allaité
mes trois enfants j'ai pu à le faire
c'est beaucoup mieux à à l'époque si je
vous disais même on venait me je tirais
du lait et on venait l'acheter à la
clinique où j'étais j'ai pas de projet
pas de compte c'est en fonction de la
maman voilà et pourquoi oui ça peut lui
apporter des immunités
je pense que la meilleure c'est la
maison maternelle pour la relation
mère enfant et puis comme aliments parce
que le lait évolué au cours de la
croissance du bébé et puis c'est hyper
commode pour parce que c'est ce qu'il ya
de mieux pour le bébé ça et puis c'est
une relation complètement intime qu'on a
avec notre enfant
beaucoup de pour dans le micro trottoir
qu'on a entendu ce soir beaucoup de
mensonges
ils sont ils sont en tout cas favorable
et ont fait ce choix je peux vous pose
également la question où vous avez des
enfants vous avez fait le choix de les
allaiter
oui tout à fait et ça a été pour vous
une une évidence où vous avez aussi une
longue période de réflexion pour mon
premier bébé c'est tout je suis passé
par une période de réflexion parce que
je l'avais pas encore fait mais pour le
deuxième comme ça s'est bien passé pour
le premier c'est une évidence et aussi
ça a quelquefois quelques mamans pour
qui ça ne se passe pas toujours bien sûr
le premier donc au deuxième aussi elle
évite donc effectivement il faut aussi
voir au cas par cas
exactement voilà vous nous l'avez
expliqué vous ne milite et pas mais en
tout cas vous accompagner et vous donner
tout tout tout l'argumentaire nécessaire
toutes les informations nécessaires
semaine de l'allaitement qui débute le
15 vous allez y participer vous allez
animer des rendez vous oui
j'anime un rendez vous pour les
professionnels de santé à l'hôpital de
versailles donc l'hôpital mignot le 18
octobre
merci d'être venu sur ce plateau d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation vous êtes
consultante en lactation et puis si vous
voulez en savoir plus un site internet
et s'est affiché sur l'écran au cours de
cet entretien la semaine de
l'allaitement débute lundi
c'est parti pour la vaccination contre
la grippe le vaccin est disponible dans
les pharmacies
la caisse primaire d'assurance maladie
fait parvenir en ce moment à ses assurés
des bons de prise en charge pour leur
permettre de les retirer gratuitement
dans les officines dans le département
215 1480 assurés sont concernés ce sont
les plus de 65 ans les personnes
atteintes d'affections de longue durée
ou était entouré de nourrissons de moins
de six mois cette année les femmes
enceintes et les personnes souffrant
d'une forte obésité sont aussi invités à
se faire vacciner
voilà pour le vaccin le vaccin qui est
donc disponible contre la grippe on
reste dans le domaine de la santé avec
cette opération menée par la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie baptisée
santé active au lieu de rembourser les
soins l'idée est de mettre l'accent sur
la prévention d'abord déployé à poissy
le dispositif va être testée prochaine
on va être testée prochainement à saint
quentin en yvelines regarde et si la
caisse primaire d'assurance-maladie
changer de nom pour s'appeler caisse
primaire d'assurance santé
si au lieu de rembourser les soins elle
les prévenait une idée toute simple mise
en place dans le département d'abord à
poissy et prochainement à saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est l'opération santé active ouverte à
tous les assurés sociaux du régime
général
les ateliers collectifs proposés autour
de trois thématiques le coeur le dos et
la nutrition il s'agit de proposer un
service de coaching santé alors le
coaching en santé qu'est ce que c'est
en fait c'est accompagner au quotidien
des personnes qui ne sont pas malades
pour préserver leur capital santé
celui effectivement à l'évolution des
dépenses de santé aujourd'hui à des
pathologies convoi croissante
par exemple si on regarde
la pathologie du diabète on voit qu'il
ya une augmentation croissante et les
courbes d'évolution montre que d'ici à
quelques années le nombre de personnes
diabétiques pour a presque triplé à
saint quentin en yvelines le dispositif
est pour l'instant expérimental
les ateliers vont démarrer à partir du 6
novembre et des inscriptions doivent se
prendre les 18 et 30 octobre à
l'institut de promotion de la santé à
trappes partenaires de l'opération
c'est la prévention primaire le but
étant de passer des informations
générales à la base et de donner des
outils par le biais d'ateliers avec des
ateliers théoriques et des ateliers
pratiques du saumon des mises en
condition
je passe sur pense surtout à l'activité
physique ou là par contre la personne va
être acteur pendant son atelier ces
ateliers de prévention sont gratuits
l'opération santé active a été mise en
place il ya cinq mois sur le territoire
de poissy et la ceppm enregistré 450
adhérents une étude interne ne
démontreraient qu'un tel dispositif
étendu à l'échelle nationale pourrait
permettre à l'assurance maladie de
réaliser 200 millions d'euros
d'économies